whoa fake loop fake loop i got my fork i got my fork hello
everybody hello i am very overworked right now i i will give
it eight i'll tell you my sleep schedule it's not because i
couldn't sleep it's because um work has been not ideal
that's all that's all i'll say it's been it's been a lot I
can't say what, but it's been a lot.
It's been a lot of work.
Just a lot.
That's what makes it not ideal.
Goddamn pastokia.
So, so that rascal, that fucking rascal pastokia, you silly
girl.
also i was so angry and stressed out um because i ordered
like um those chips with dips and stuff so i ordered salmon
um and i was angry because i was having a conversation um
with my manager about some stuff and then i hit the top of
the chip on the gum on the gum of where like where my My
front teeth connects to my gum and I hit it right there.
And now it's not bleeding or anything.
It was the first time that has ever happened to me.
And yeah, I stabbed myself with fucking tortilla chip.
And then like it's not bleeding, but it's just, it was,
it's, I think it's swollen right now.
And you know, like when, when you're like, something feels
weird and then you keep like licking your tongue on it and
be like, why is this so weird?
And it makes it not, I won't say it makes it worse, but then
you get paranoid and overthink and be like, am I making it
worse?
Is my teeth gonna fall out?
Afterwards, am I making it work?
Oh no, what if it falls out of the world?
Also, I realized the watch and stuff is still there, so I
removed that.
So, just a lot.
I'm just, I'm surviving.
I wanted to stream earlier.
Okay, so I wanted to stream on Twitch earlier.
But...
Um, this was my schedule.
Um, oh, fuck, where did I even start?
Where did I?
Where did I even start?
Okay.
Yesterday, I was literally hibernating.
Yesterday was just hibernation.
Like, I didn't exist as a person.
I was awake yesterday for three hours.
That was how bad it was.
It was like, I woke up at five yesterday.
I woke up five yesterday did work stuff I was so tired
because I did a lot of stuff on today's Tuesday right well
technically it's Wednesday now but on Monday it was just all
on Sunday I was literally just working non-stop and because
I was so fucking tired so on Monday I literally like woke up
at around like fourish to five worked for like three hours
had a meal ate like pizza like like there i gave like three
slices of pizza because there was a pizza place nearby so i
just went and grabbed like three slices pizza eight eight
and then i was so tired and i was just like i'll take a
little bit of a nap and i slept for i think like i slept for
four more hours and like i think i went yeah at around eight
around eightish to nine i was like oh i'm so tired Like, I
can't do more work right now.
And then I went to bed.
I wanted to take another nap around 8-ish to 9.
And I woke up around, like, one.
Close to one.
And then I was like, fuck.
And I went and worked.
I worked all the way till 9 a.m.
And then, and then I took another nap because I was just
like, I can't.
I'm tired.
Woke up.
at I think around I don't even remember
around two I think two or three did more stuff then took and
then and then got tired again at 6 p.m.
and then took another nap and then woke up at 8 that's my
schedule that's That's my schedule right now.
Alright, then here we are.
But it's not like I slept like from like 1 to 8 p.m.
It was just I woke up at 1 and then did work again, got
tired at 6, and then woke up at 8.
So I took another 2 hour nap.
So here we are.
So it's just, you know how like there's a sleep schedule
where it's just based on power napping?
I'm not intentionally doing that, but it's somehow morphed
into like there's no schedule anymore.
um it's like i would love to have a schedule right now but i
you know you guys don't understand like you guys will find
out when everything is revealed why i've been all over the
place like what i've been working on has to be like the most
stressful experience of my life like
i've never been more stressed before with what i've been
working on when do we i don't even know
Like I have to Like it's not like Like I just like I have to
get like Get all this done Like Like I've never been Like
I've never been So stressed before in my life Working in my
streaming career Until well no that's a lie But like But
like Since I came back so far
so far
um anyway next seat thank you for the thousand bitties thank
you thank you you do want to set a constant change in your
sleep so it makes you more tired than it because i it's not
on per i swear to god me changing my schedule all this all
the time it's not on purpose it's just it's just like i'm
just not forced to because I chose to do this to myself as
well but like you'll understand when it's all revealed like
I can't explain it without spoiling what the fuck is going
on so I just say it will all reveal itself in due time and
then you guys would be like oh that's why Doki was so fucked
up like I was like huh they give it a tier one so they I
can't say anything yet it's just time will tell when time
comes you'll understand
so so that's that's basically it i'm not okay i'm not i'm
not i'm not okay i'm i have salmon though salmon's good for
the brain god i hope so i need i need brain recovery right
now Holy shit, Husky!
Thank you so much.
Husky, thank you so much for the 50 gifted.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh my god, thank you so much.
That's insane.
Thank you, Husky.
Thank you for the support.
Um.
I hope eventually it will fix itself.
I hope.
But like, there's an end to this.
There is an end to this.
this tunnel, I don't know whether or not, well, not for you
guys, because then you guys still have, you might have to
wait still before whatever it is gets announced, whatever it
is, whatever it could be, whatever it's going to be
revealed, whatever's going to be real, but for me, the
tunnel is ending soon.
The tunnel is ending soon, so I just, it's gotta persevere
for a little longer just a little bit longer it's almost
done it's almost well not almost but like it's it's there i
can see the light finally i can see the light i don't know
for you guys you guys might not know yet what it is but
don't rework yourself too hard i'm trying i'm trying it's
just there's no choice right now i have to overwork myself
or then like we fall behind because there are deadlines
there are deadlines to everything and i can't like i can't
like be like oops um i might need an extension because
there's already been several extensions so so i gotta i
gotta just tank it until until i get to i know i see the
light all right anyway i was gonna talk i'm gonna talk about
this on the youtube stream too but i posted i can't i posted
a photo of on Twitter.
I'm not gonna show it on Twitch.
The end of the quote was jailed for his crimes.
And I was surprised that no one noticed.
That no one replied with the most obvious reason of why he
could be jailed for his crimes.
It's not why he was jailed.
He was like in the car.
But I'm surprised no one had mentioned it.
for someone to say indecent exposure.
I was waiting for someone to say that.
But no one did.
Oh, I know.
Toki.
Why would...
I don't know.
It's a good reply.
Because people were like, what did he do?
Like, him he didn't do nothing oh my god that is always
exposing not so i really respect him i just thought that was
funny because i just thought someone would 150 comments and
And no one mentioned indecent exposure.
No one.
That's
a crime.
That's a fucking crime.
Cross, thank you for the red.
Thank you.
I hope you had a good stream.
Not for daddy's a tie.
all right anyway rules are different for a dog anyway so
that's really that's just really what i wanted to say about
that photo i thought it was funny i was like why does he
look so fucking sad like he looks so depressed i was like
what's right why are you so sad we're going home
That's why.
It's like, bring me back.
Yeah.
I don't know, but I have no plan.
I just wanted to, I just wanted to stream today because I
feel like, I wanted to stream today, but I didn't want to
commit to it.
anything only because like i said like my schedule right now
is all over the place right now with what i have to be what
i have to do behind the scenes um eventually it's gonna
stabilize so april's just april's just crazy april april's
not my month that's for sure it's just not my month so i i
don't really know what to do i thought about like maybe
playing i don't know i don't know if i want watch right now
where I want to play rivals um I have to play rivals though
like eventually because I need to remember I'll play the
game uh for next week and if you know you know like
if you know you know I'm so um so there's all that I mean I
couldn't play rivals just to remember how to play the game
um or could like look on steam and see what's what is there
to do honestly
any knowers in chat all right you guys see the new leon
statue i don't think it's official i think it's one of those
like is this okay wait um ex-superhero studio i'm just
wondering this has to be like one of those the um the
chinese figure resin brands right Because I know some of
them are official and some of them aren't.
So I can't tell if this is like the official figure brand.
Or are they like fan?
Yeah, the one where Leon is handcuffed to a chair.
And there's a shirtless version of him.
Even though I'm pretty sure he was not shirtless in the
game.
I don't know.
Maybe I blacked out when it happened.
So maybe it happened.
And like I blacked out.
And I just forgot about it.
So I was like.
Because there are, like, really good resin figures.
There aren't official figures.
And, God, and, like, they're, like, really high quality.
Because I do own a couple of them.
Not the Resident Evil one.
Not the Leon one.
But I do own, like, a couple of the Pokemon ones.
They make really good, like, Pokemon resin figures, too.
And I used to, like, when I used to collect Pokemon resin,
like, when I used to collect figures, I owned several
Pokemon resin figures from the unofficial, like, figure
companies.
Because they're really high quality.
Wait, let me show you guys one.
of them let's see it was like the charmander resin figure
let me see i could find it it's one of my favorite i showed
this before it's one of my favorite uh resin figures uh it's
a charmander um and then the light and then the okay here
i'll show you guys it's really pretty um let me see Oh, it's
this one.
I found it.
It's this one.
It's unofficial, but like, um, it's one of my favorite, I
guess, like, uh, grails, I guess.
Even though it's, like, unofficial is this.
And, like, the tail, the tail lights up, too.
Like, there's, like, a LED light in the tail, and it lights
up.
It's super high.
It's very, very fucking heavy, too.
Because it's, it's literally resin.
So, it's a resin statue.
And all these aren't official figures, but they're all,
like, super fucking high quality.
There's another one I have.
It was, like, Pikachu, Ponyta, Resin figure.
I own two.
These are the two I have.
Um, where is it?
Oh, where is it?
See, Pikachu.
Pikachu.
Where is it?
Galarian.
Ponita.
Maybe.
Present.
Pikachu.
Hoodie.
Galaria.
Oh my, it's so hard to find.
I have not found a single image of this yet.
It is very specific.
So it's very cute too.
Because it's like.
It's based off of Galaria.
uh ponita ponita and like the her the like the what's it
called the hair the ponita hair is like see-through and it's
really pretty it's very expensive too uh which is why like i
think like the moment i became a vtuber i just collected
myself i stopped i stopped collecting figures and i started
collecting myself because i was like this means more I am my
own biggest fan I
Okay Pikachu But it's true though I like literally I used to
like collect a lot of figures and stuff like that Because I
was like this is pretty It was my hobby And in the moment I
became a YouTuber I was just like This is now my new hobby I
am my own hobby self love is important guys love yourself oh
my god it's what the fuck i really want to show you guys
this picture resin hoodie figure i really want to show you
guys it's so pretty um i mean i can find it in my email okay
because i remember the website i saved the website for it
and everything.
Oh, there it is.
Okay.
I know the company that made it too.
What the fuck?
Where are the pictures?
Is this one?
Oh my god, where is it?
I will find this, guys.
This is very important.
You know, I could just find it on my phone.
I'm pretty sure I took a picture it on my phone i i'm pretty
fucking i'm pretty sure i okay wait let me do one more
google search if not i'll just find it on my phone i'm
pretty sure i took a picture of it it's so pretty too like i
see like the other ones like the the bobasaur one and
everything but i can't find the okay i can't find the one i
want and show this god damn it okay view my order can i
still view my order after all this time after like six years
like after six years does it still exist i would be very
surprised no This page doesn't seem to exist.
Okay, yeah, that seems right.
That seems right.
I don't think it would exist after six years.
I'm sad.
I really, really wanted to show you guys this particular
resin statue.
Because it is really pretty.
Wait, Pikachu.
I don't understand.
Like, it's just gone.
Like, the pictures.
Like, actually, the pictures.
pictures are just god i don't even see like any of the
pictures for it that's crazy like i don't they don't have
like photos of it what happened did it like got did it got
like dmca'd by nintendo by the pokemon company and they're
like we we must delete this from existence before they can
sue us like but like just that one just that particular
version Like, it doesn't make sense to me.
Why is it only that that got wiped from the internet?
I said, if it never happened, the Nintendo lawyer got him.
But just that one, there's a Sylveon version.
And then there's, but like, where the fuck is the Galarian?
All right, there is, I do have, I found one picture of it.
But it's like, so small.
That, wait, maybe.
Maybe I can do a Google reverse search.
Google image search.
All right.
I'm going to do a Google reverse image.
Search by image.
I will find you.
I do not find him.
It's not there.
Even Google reverse doesn't know.
Google reverse is like, what is this?
What the fuck?
Like, I see, like, the other ones.
Like, it's crazy.
see like the other ones that they've done of the of
different like pokemon but the galarian ponita ponita is the
only one that's missing like that it doesn't make sense like
i don't understand where is it i took i took her pills fb
studio like i remember the studio and everything but it's
like it's like they never they were never here It's like,
they never existed.
It was just like a figment of my imagination.
But like, it happened.
I have the receipt and everything.
Okay, I'll show you guys the only evidence I have.
That it was real.
Give me a sec.
I saved it.
Apparently not.
Okay, let me...
All right.
yeah but um bum bum all right she is hallucinating all right
it looked like this this is what it looked like like I
there's apparently no more like it's just god there's no
pictures of it anymore I I swear to god like I this is what
it looked like and you can't find it anywhere and it's So
you can have the light come up and everything, like the hair
and everything, and it's see-through.
Like, there's different ones.
I found, like, there's, like, different versions of Pikachu.
It was different Pokemon, but the Galarium was just gone.
It just never existed.
I can't find any record of it anywhere.
It just doesn't exist anymore.
This was pre-AI.
I literally owned a physical statue of this somewhere.
I don't know where it is right now.
But also, like, this is another one that they've done.
They did a melodic one.
But, like, obviously, like, this is from the same company.
It's like, it's from the same company.
But, like, the Galarian Ponita one is, like, my favorite
version.
Like, when I saw that, I have to have it.
It was just so cute.
so cute but like i don't know what the fuck happened like
they just ceased to exist like they just disappeared for
some reason they have so many other versions of it there's a
laparous one there's a uh there's a laparous one there's
like a cinderquill one there's a umbrion one i can find it
on google right now but yet somehow the ponita the galarian
Ponyta it's just gone they like it nowhere the only evidence
I have that it ever existed on the internet is this photo
from my email from my inbox like the tanias like uh 100 by
100 in little boxes be like congratulations for purchasing
this product that's the only image I have of it Yeah, it's
literally lost media.
It's like the Bearstein Bears.
I brought it from, you know that theory?
Where, um, the Bearstein, the Bearstein and
Bearstein-Bairstein universes collided together.
So that's why some people remember it as Bearstein and some
people remember as Bearstein.
Because, like, both universes collided.
with each other and combine together and that's why it's the
half the people think it's barista and half the people think
it's baristaine i was from the ponita galarian universe but
only i made it only i made it over and i'm the only one that
remembers its existence
me and my me and my hotmail inbox made it to this universe
to show you guys galarian ponita
that's crazy
everything else is the same everything else we share
everything the same except for some reason Just this item
exists in my universe.
And this, yeah, no.
Harami is still dead in my universe.
It was just this one difference.
This is the only thing that was different compared to
everything else.
Oh, I posted high quality of this image in 2021.
All right, end my Twitter account.
End my Twitter account.
existed.
I managed to bring my Twitter account over to this universe.
Anyway, I just want to talk about that.
Well, I originally want to talk about naked Leon Kennedy
statue.
Like, I don't know, I don't know.
Some of you guys are like, oh man.
I hope, I hope you don't give me a link.
I sure I definitely don't want that.
Where can I find it so I can block it from my browser
history?
Don't worry, guys.
I will give you guys the link so you can block the website
and block the user, you know?
So I would really hate that.
What's the link so I can be sure I can be sure to block it.
Don't worry, I'm looking out for you guys.
Yay.
I'm so thoughtful.
But yeah.
That's...
I'm going to click on the link anyway.
Security verification.
Man, that's a lot of people going on our website.
Ha ha ha ha.
Ha ha.
That's a lot of people going on there to block it,
obviously, to block the website, guys.
That's why there were so many people that was trying to
access it.
They had to put security up because so many people wanted to
block it.
Can we check the purchase limit?
Oh yeah, you gotta get three.
One where he has a shirt.
One where he's shirtless.
One where he just has his pants on.
You know, you have all the variation.
Wait, there's actually...
Wait, why is there four versions?
What's the difference between version one?
Okay, version one.
Version B and version...
Oh, it's bigger.
There's a miniature version.
Wait, there's one version where they're like...
It's just a smaller size.
It's just like a smaller size.
size it's just a miniature naked leon and then you can stack
the pocket leon
all right you guys see the whole invincible discourse right
now where um everyone is mad about the animation i will i
read the invincible comics by the way um the only thing the
thing i will say um the one the thing i will say that uh uh
wait png dragon wait what about what what png i didn't watch
the newest and i didn't watch the newest uh the newest
episodes yet i watched like the first three um i don't know
if you're i what exactly the expanding dragon png i is it
from the newest episode i didn't watch it oh it's an episode
four i watched episode three i don't think i wait did i
which one wait which one is the one where um where it's just
the backstory of nolan and he got his shit beat up by his
parents which one was that we got beat up by his parents
that's the last last okay episode two i stopped episode two
so um uh because I've just been busy it's not because I was
like fuck this episode two was the one where he got beat up
by his parents was pretty good um I mean not because he was
getting beat up by his parents I just thought the writing
was really good um but the reason why I stopped was just
like I said I was so behind on everything so I was just
working on it um but anyway this is my opinion on it as
someone that read the invincible comics um I a lot of the
characters the recent one in the last two seasons i don't
really fuck with the voice actors like the the voice acting
for it because it was not how i imagined that they would
sound like because like a lot of them i was just like why is
there especially when their voices are much higher than i
expected i swear it feels like they're like allergic to like
deep voices and stuff yeah they didn't Like, yeah, it's cool
that they got Lee Pace.
It was a Lee Pace, right?
Pushing Dazies guy.
Is that his name?
I mean, cool that they got Lee Pace to voice drag.
But, like, I thought his voice would be deeper, honestly.
I thought he would have had a deeper voice.
He sounds too, like, I don't know, not as intimidating as I
thought he would sound.
Conquest too.
I didn't like how like High his like he's a big ass
motherfucker You know, he's fucking built like a goddamn
tank And you would think his voice would be lower and be
like yeah, you know Like I'm gonna kill you.
I'm so lonely, but he's like I'm so lonely.
And I'm like I don't know It's just You know what I mean?
He's like I'm so lonely
Like, and he's old, too, you know, like, like, he's a lot
older, and when you're older, um, when you're older, your,
your voice gets deeper, too, and he's like, he's a fucking
old man, he's super fucking old, like, and he's like a
strong old man, too, but his voice is, like, was a lot
higher than I expected, so, but, like, you know, he's, he's
also a famous actor,
uh i i just or like raspy you know just just not did not
give me conquest vibes it didn't give me like conquest vibes
and also same with drag it didn't give me like dictator guy
that literally killed committed like genocide and killed
thousands and thousands of planets it didn't really give me
that feeling i was just like that's lee pace don't like
that's him wow he got paid a million dollar like he got paid
500 grand per episode good for him
so um i just feel like i think it sucked definitely sucked
that um people were like the animation prep yeah some of
them get paid like 300 grand per rep like a lot just like uh
i don't And there was a little thing, invincible voice
acting pay per episode.
There was, like, a graphic about it.
And I was like, yeah, majority of the budget literally went
towards just voice acting.
Okay, maybe not 300k, but still per episode, though.
It's just not a lot of episodes.
I think the only one that deserved it was Stephen and J.K.
Simmons because they're literally like the main people and
they're really, really good.
But then there's some where I like don't agree as much but
here's the invincible voice actor.
I just feel like definitely more budget show definitely went
with on animation because like it's like a million dollars
per episode or some shit, right?
Yeah, it's like the budget is like a million not a million
what is it yeah i mean with the amount of people there a
million per episode i feel like you know if it's a million
per episode maybe like the animation quality could be a
little higher i feel like um instead of like just getting uh
uh instead of just getting like uh a-listers because like
regular voice actors can do the same thing because that's
what it was like before Aladdin for those who don't know it
was because of Aladdin that now we just get celebrities
voice acting everything uh and it's more it's because of
like Aladdin was like the first sort of like big Hollywood
movie that casted a big celebrity Robin Williams to do a to
voice acting in animation um and it started the trend
because they're like if we put this actor's name in it
people are going to watch the movie and that's basically
like that's basically the advertising meta where they're
just like oh we put a big celebrity in and that's what's
going to sell tickets for people to watch the show that's
what's going to base like boost um the boost the ratings and
stuff but i feel like a lot of voice actors can perform
better than some of the voice actors with like less of a
budget yeah but like no atlanta was the first one that
really like set the tone for it and people were like wait it
worked because like they literally just plastered uh robin
williams name everywhere on the posters and that's why robin
williams at disney had their feud because robin williams was
like i'll only do it as long as like everyone gets like um
gets like the same credit or like what was it called like
get like similar attention uh regarding like uh credits but
then after he signed the contract and everything and did all
the voice acting and everything uh yeah the same billing
like they just plastered his name everywhere on posters and
then that's why they had like a huge feud where robin
williams like i don't want to do anything with disney and
that's why the voice of homer simpson became the voice of
genie for a while because he literally didn't want to come
back to do it he didn't want to come back uh to do anything
with disney and so they got homer simpson to be the voice of
genie yeah but they made up for it they made it that's why
he came back like that's why he was indicted to the was it
the disney hall of fame or some shit later on went like
after he's like all right after like 30 plus years i'm okay
now or like 20 plus years yeah i miss used to hire like it's
just cartoons now mostly if you want to like but then like
the thing is it's a lot of old blood too it's very clicky as
well for voice acting community because it's like um it's
very hard for new blood to to uh get into like the voice
acting community because it's just very it's such a hard
community to like to like reach into and then um and also
the fact that like you know they're always hiring the same
voice actors over and over again because it's like uh
they're like you know they have so much experience over the
years they can do like 800 different voices for one like for
just hire one person to do like 20 voices and then you save
money and everything um uh and it's like you know they're
they are able to rely on them because they already had a lot
of history in the in uh in the job, they already have a lot
of history in the community and everything, and they're
reliable.
So it's pretty scary to hire new blood because you don't
know if you can rely on them, or you don't know if they can
be up for the challenge and everything.
So it's really hard to find new blood when it comes to voice
acting and stuff.
Especially when a lot of voice actors are getting a lot of
the well-known voice actors that we know and that we're so
familiar with.
Already getting super old, like Tom Kenny.
You can tell how much his voice has aged on SpongeBob.
uh where like you know when he was you know a lot younger he
was doing sponge bob voices and it's like a lot you know if
that definitely is a lot younger but then if you hear a new
sponge bob you can tell like how much he's aged doing sponge
bob because it's like a lot deeper now a less less shrill um
and not as clean as it was before it's a little sad it's a
little sad when you hear like the comparison.
And it's like, I would see like, whenever like new shows
come out, it's always like the same voice actors that you've
like seen over and over again over like the span of 20 and
30 years.
It doesn't mean like, you know, like I'm like, yeah, fuck
them.
Like, boycott.
It's just like, be nice to see new blood.
And it's getting a little scary that, like, you know, it's
getting a little scary that we aren't seeing a lot of new
blood in the voice acting community as well.
Quill, thank you for the super chat.
Oh, no, sorry.
Thank you for the five.
It's been a while since I streamed on Twitch, guys.
Thank you for the 500 bitties.
Thank you.
I might have an 8 a.m.
tomorrow, but I'm clocking in for this late night stream.
Please take care of yourself.
Thank you for the bitties.
Thank you.
Yeah, but at least people getting paid more in voice acting,
though.
Yeah, it is.
It is a little worrisome with how hard it is to, like, get
into voice acting as well.
um because it's such a it's it's like it's also like who you
know like i think that's a lot regarding entertainment the
entertainment is all about like who you know like right time
right opportunity um and everything um it's not not just
like oh you are a talented voice actor it's also about like
the connections you have or like oh you're a very talented
actor you're a very talented singer it's also like the
connections you have and everything and like um who you know
stuff too i want to see shows with doki's voice acting i can
do only two voices this voice and then a kid guys i don't
think any voice acting acting company is hiring i can and
also march that's literally that's literally like all the
voices I can do.
I don't think I can call myself a voice actor.
I literally have three voices.
My regular talking voice.
Me talking like a kid.
And then I was a parent that I'm really bad at reading a
script apparently from what you guys did.
It's like, oh man, scripted Doki.
Yay!
Yay, scripted Doki is back.
Every time, every time I read a script, you guys are like,
Yes, script the dokey!
It's so obvious.
I don't know how to fucking read scripts, apparently.
Yeah, I'll just be like, I'll be like, Hey, yo, everyone.
The sponsor, boys.
All right, sorry, I had another work miss.
message.
I mean, if anyone wants to hire me, I'll play myself.
That's the least scripted thing you can get.
Even when I play myself, I still sound like I'm reading from
a script.
There's no winning for me.
There's no... Just be a dokey.
Take acting lessons.
I was actually a drama kid before I went Before I went to do
backstage.
What was it called?
Is that what it's called?
Backstage light.
Like I was in lighting after that.
I was like really into drama and stuff and like being
expressive.
But it wasn't like good acting.
It was more so of just being like, like theater, I guess
theater acting where you're super, uh, where you're more
expressive than you should, like than actual acting acting.
Um, I was really good at it because, uh, because when, you
know, when you're in middle school, everyone's always so
embarrassed to like do stuff publicly in drama class and it
was mandatory by the way yeah it was like fucking mandatory
everyone had to do drama uh drama that was the only one that
was like willing to like embarrass myself because i had no
shame back then i still sort of don't depends on the
circumstance um it depends on what i have to do it's like 50
50 sometimes i have no shame sometimes i do um and so but
like in middle school i was like the one the one student
that literally had no shame in doing anything so like if
they want me to fucking act something out or to be stupid
i'll do it um because it's like but then like the thing is
um uh the teacher there were there was like this academic uh
conference for uh god i don't remember what it was called
but the teacher will pick one student uh for to represent
for to represent each art so one student from middle school
will represent the art department one student from music
slash uh from band will represent like one student will be
representing band for the entire middle school one student
will be representing choir for the entire school and one
student will be representing drama slash theater for the
entire school I was picked for the theater one and i was
just like what the fuck like i didn't i didn't even know
this existed and then you know it was like it's supposed to
be like a huge honor to be picked because it's like sixth
grade to eighth grade and um and i don't remember i think i
was like seventh grade when i got seventh seventh grade or
sixth grade to be picked and we get to we have to travel to
like a different city or a country depending on where the
conference is held i think at that time the conference was
held in Beijing around that time and so uh we all like got
to travel uh to like it like it's like multiple schools in
like it's multiple schools it's not just like you know uh
it's like a giant school like giant like conference with
surrounding schools from the from like several countries and
so I was really nervous oh I got chosen twice sorry I got
chosen twice uh oh and backstage I remember now okay sorry I
was chosen twice in a row but one was for drama and then the
other one was for backstage because I I I was like fuck
drama because I hated the nepotism um during like I changed
my role because I hated the nepotism when it came to like uh
what was it when it came to like uh school musicals and
plays because I auditioned for uh the Cheshire cat and I
thought I was perfect for the Cheshire Cat.
I thought I fucking nailed the audition for the Cheshire
Cat, but because I was in seventh grade and they gave the
role to eighth graders because they're like, well, they're
gonna go to high school soon.
So, wait, let me see.
Wait, no, they were seniors.
They were, they're graduate like, well, they're gonna
graduate.
I was in eighth ninth grader so it was eighth grade and
ninth grade sorry i keep changing the dates because i'm like
vaguely remembering it slowly i eighth grade and ninth grade
i got picked back to back for these for this conference and
uh but ninth grade i thought i fucking nailed my audition
for cheshire cat and then and then i saw the list and then i
got i got the fucking walrus or some shit or the clam I
don't fucking read the the lot the one word I get one line
because I was a freshman like I don't even remember what
character it was either the walrus or the fucking clown I
was so mad because I read the whole script and I remember
they had like one scene and one line but I nailed my
audition because everyone was like well like they're like
that was so good and I like fell at one point but I like I
like made it seem like it was part of the character and was
like wow that's so cool that you like like that you fake
fall there and to sell the character and everything because
i was just like well and then then i found out i got fucking
the walrus or the clam whatever it was i just remember it
was one line and then gave it to like a senior and then i
was told that it's because she was graduating you know
because she's the seniors like this is our last chance to be
in a to be in a play uh because she's going she does her
last chance play so you give the like the big roles to the
seniors and then i was so mad that i was like this i'm gonna
do backstage i was gonna be like the backstage lights
because i do enjoy doing lights too because sometimes i
volunteer to do lights and stuff uh depending on like uh uh
like you know i just it's just fun and the one the teacher
that handles the lights he was my favorite teacher and
everything um he's always been super nice to me he was also
canadian too um uh mr mcdonald well i don't know if he
watches if you're watching you were a baller you're g bro
you're
you're a great teacher mr mac i respect you
w mac um anyway uh bro i loved i loved having him as a
teacher he was actually a really good teacher um he was
super nice to me and everything uh and he was also canadian
so i was like canadians represent because this is an
international school you know um anyway uh and he was also
like i said he was like the main lights guy so he taught me
all about the lights and stuff before as well and then i was
like fuck this i'm going straight to lights i'm not fuck
this i don't want to do either one line any so that was the
lights i learned i do lights and stuff and basically did
like the backstage production stuff for majority of plays
and everything um after that and then so like on eighth in
ninth grade i got picked to be the representative for
backstage and behind the scenes like light technician uh uh
for the conference So yeah, oh, and then like with all of
that, like for the end of the conference, like during the
whole conference, like I said, during the whole conference,
it's basically like everyone coming together from like,
because it's like a bunch of student representatives from
each school representing band, choir, art, and drama and
backstage, I don't know, technician, what is the word for?
I don't remember what it's called, behind the scenes
backstage.
conference uh throughout the conference they all work
together uh they all oh stage hat they all work together to
create like something to perform as a big like recital
basically so like like all the choir kids from all the
different schools like perform together from different
schools uh and like you know perform like a set and then
same with the band they all like all the like the
representatives and band like uh perform something together
the same with drama and then they do a play or a musical,
like a mini play or a mini musical and stuff like that.
And everything.
So it was a very cool experience.
Like it was a giant collab with various students from
around, like from, I won't say around the world.
But like in international schools around Asia.
And it was a really cool experience.
So I got to experience that as a drama student and also a
stage hand for it.
um and uh i'll tell you my first experience as a drama
student because i didn't expect myself to get picked i
didn't even know this fucking thing existed um in eighth
grade and it's crazy because i was so embarrassed you know i
was so fucking embarrassed because like i i can embarrass
myself and i have no shame when i'm in front of my peers
like my classmates and stuff because like i know who they
are and like you know it's fun whatever i don't really have
shame with doing all of this but then i was dropped in this
like environment where i don't fucking know like who the
fuck these people are like i don't know who they are like
like i've never seen these people before and i have to be
there because it was like a free trip you know it's like
free trip yay and then it was like a huge like you know for
my um like uh you know for my resume for my cv for applying
to university and stuff so then what's fucking funny it was
what makes it embarrassing was in eighth grade as a drama
representative we were going to perform cats
we're gonna perform cat we're gonna perform cat no i was
like oh no so we had to do a warm-up session like an
icebreaker and then the the super the head drama teacher um
that was the head of like all of us they're at the
conference like the main that was gonna direct all of this
was like let's do a warm-up uh for a cats production uh
we're gonna do cats and then we're gonna do a warm let
everyone pretend we're gonna do one by one to this music to
this song and all our drama teachers by the way like the
drama teachers So, you know, they want us to do well to be
like, to reflect the school and be like, yeah, that's my
student.
You know, they want us to reflect this.
They want, like, they were all, all of our drama teachers
were there watching.
And they're like, all right, to the song.
We're all standing in line and go one by one to act like a
cat.
Um, in the tune of this song.
And I was so embarrassed.
was my turn and I just, I just walked, walked from one
direction to the next without doing anything.
I was like, I don't want to be here no more.
And then my teacher pulled me aside and was like, you're
embarrassing me.
She like pulled me aside after I walked to the end.
I was like, you're embarrassing me right now.
I picked you because I thought you were the best in the
school right now for this.
And I was like, don't make me regret my decision.
And I was just like, I don't know where to do this.
And
So I went back to the line and I acted the shit out of being
a cat, but I was not feeling it.
I was not feeling it at all.
It was not a great time for me.
I was like, I was so excited.
And then they were like, we're going to do cats.
We're going to do cats for our protection.
I was like, no, not cats.
Oh my god.
Cats.
Anyway, during the final day, I had to, I literally wore the
cat's costume, by the way.
I, I had the tail.
I had the bodysuit.
They put the cat makeup on.
I don't remember anything of what the fuck I did in it.
But I remembered the costume.
for the cats too i i was so i was in the cats production
next see thank you for the videos thank you thank you if
they all need they can see a dog kitty now uh kayla's
thinking of them 150s thank you thank you my primary school
did a bugsy malone plan i surprisingly did the most
authentic brooklyn italian mafia accent of everyone it's all
thanks to who framed roger the rabbit thank you for the
hundred bitties thank you thank you don't kitty i don't do
not group go don't kitty the cats don't kitty does not
deserve that uh anyway the year after that i was behind i
was a techie i was a stage hat after that i fucking swap
roles i
I have king, I have king swap roles.
I was like, never again.
But yeah, anyway.
Yes, I was a, I was a theater kid.
But like, I was good at exaggeration.
Like, like not actually acting, acting to make it seem like,
oh my God, it feels so real.
It's just more so being like, hello, everybody.
What's up?
Yep.
Yeah, it was just shit like that.
Like, it was fine.
Reading a script for a Tresha or a cat was so easy.
Because you just gotta be, like, mischievous and goofy.
Not, like, super goofy.
But you know what I mean, right?
You'd be like, hello.
Like, you know, like, just like this fucking weird-ass cat.
Like, you're not, like, you're not, like, acting.
You're acting, but you're not, like, acting, acting.
like okay a little lord dump for you guys
yeah I'm not good at method oh so I need water I'm not good
at method acting I mean maybe I'm good I'm surprisingly very
good at method acting as a teenage boy because that's just
my humor okay let me get water I'll be right back guys
I'm back I don't know what I want to do we do have an actual
stream like like tomorrow later today technically not
tomorrow but later today so i don't know i actually want to
do anything right now um will you sleep after this stream i
gotta do some behind the scenes rick so there's no there's
light but there's not there yet there's light in the tunnel
but but like i'm very far from the light it's like a little
dot in the distance i was like is that light is that oh my
god i see the dot
i see it i just gotta make it i just gotta get there
I don't know what to play.
That's just sniping out your ear forever to make sure you
stay in that hole.
And we could practice Rivals.
It has been a while since I played Rivals.
So Elo, Elo, and I feel I'm going to get yelled at.
I know, actually, no, I know I'm going to get yelled at.
another puzzle i don't know if i want to do a puzzle to be
fair it was that raccoon game the right coin or some shit
because i love coin push i mean well i don't love coin
pushers now but when i was growing up i used to love coin
pushers because it was like legal gambling for kids um and
then um and then when you're when you're always at the like
the asian arcades you would see all the uh all the grandmas
sitting there because uh uh there wasn't any casinos in hong
kong because it was illegal back then so the only legal way
to gamble was uh was to go to like the kid arcades the
children arcades and then just play coin pushers so i would
i would all yeah because you have to go to macao for that
you wanted to go to a casino you have to go to macao um
which is like the las vegas of Asia and uh uh but you know
obviously you can't really go to Macau willy nilly like
because it's like an island it's an island um so you know
like the grant the grannies uh to get their fix you would
see them in these like children arcade places and it'll all
just be like all beyond the coin pushers just sitting there
with a giant bag of coins and a and a bag for the and just
play uh coin pusher
but i also enjoyed coin pusher i thought it was fun to see
like see the coins go down it was like whoa look at this
giant stack of coins and you're like oh my god it's like a
little little tiny adrenaline rush for little dokey they're
like oh my god who would have thought legal gambling would
be so fun.
That's not going to hurt me when growing up.
Yippee.
Like, that's not going to have severe consequences to me
growing up.
Uh, uh, VTipo, thank you for the 400 bitties.
Thank you.
Hi from Europe.
Hope, I hope I don't often catch you live.
Hope you have fun.
Thank you.
The good bitties.
Yeah, that won't have lasting effects, right?
final words to live by you don't fuck it let's just do
something it has been a while since i get riled played
rivals so um do we have drops it's been a while it's drops
implemented i was maybe on overwatch or rivals but really i
can solo queue rivals but like actually i can't either one
is is not the best like i can i can stomach rivals solo Q
more than Overwatch solo Q because I realized like like when
rival people are mean it's like funny mean but when
Overwatch people are mean they like hurt your soul they like
they get you worried actually hurt like and then it's a lot
harder like um they're more experience yeah they've been
they've stuck it with it they stuck with their game for so
long like nothing matters to them anymore like they never
pivoted they never left they were true believers of
overwatch so like they they've been they were here for i
don't know 10 years of just playing oh that's just a crazy
thing about overwatch has been around for like almost 10
years and They've stuck out stuck it out for 10 years and
And they're so mean.
Oh my god.
They like actually They're literally mentally it's they like
they hurt you where you're you weren't actually hurt they
twist a knife to you're like I'm dying of cancer and there's
and then they they stuck another knife in you like maybe you
should die faster And then they twist it like
like it's like not great like solo queue is not great so i'm
just like uh the stage four why not there are like little
demons in them there's there's demons that's someone that's
been like playing overwatch off stream i i i would rather if
i have to stream overwatch i would rather do on overwatch I
can I can play it solo off stream because then I can cry to
myself like I can you know after the game ends I like turn
off my PC and then I get up and then go to bed and just cry
to myself and then get back on like so I'm just like I don't
know I can do that on stream I don't I don't know if I can I
can go through that um but for rivals I get solo cute rivals
because like i have nothing to lose more so i guess um i
mean i have nothing to lose in overwatch but like the rival
people when they're mean it doesn't like hurt me that much
because some of the people that are mean to me in rivals
they're like underage so now i'm just like bro you're just
gonna go to bro like you have school tomorrow do your
homework do your physics homework but then overwatch because
they've been playing for 10 plus year you know these people
outside of Overwatch or like have a job outside of like are
employed um and they're still they still hurt you.
Some of them are employed they have a kid or some shit right
they and they're here there they they're still here to hurt
you and or worse they aren't employed after 10 years yes
it's the other and neither of them neither of them are like
a great a great option um to encounter you know like either
they're employed or unemployed and neither of them are great
options they have the life experience that hurt me so we're
maybe um through that entire tangent i think i i think i'll
play rivals i think i'll play rivals on stream um all right
let me see
all right it's because they are employed and they channel
their work depression this is their only outlet right now
because her boss was really really mean all right what
should i here to get um let's see uh elo terrorist is back
to get yelled at
all right that's my that's my my title like i said i would
stream overage it's just it's just like i don't want to get
hurt i'm i'm scared i'm scared i really i'm tired i'm
overworked right now i i i don't want to get on solo queue
it just and it's a lot harder it's a i mean you can mute
them yeah but then like you know sometimes like you know
you're hearing one of the funny content when they're not
mean but then you have to hear them be mean and then you can
mute them so like i hear the first i still have to hear the
first sentence before i mute them because it's not fun
playing it fully mute you know and you need comms sometimes
as as well i still need the comms All right, let me close
all my tabs.
I have a lot of tabs.
I haven't been closing anything for a while.
Okay, there you go.
Yeah.
Let's see.
It has been a very long time.
Alphabash is a lot harder, too, so I can't fuck around as
much.
I think it's also because, like, there's...
Overwatch punishes you more.
I feel like when I play Support, and rivals i feel like i
could like do 70 like of the work and i still live i have an
overwatch and i don't pay attention for even like one second
it's like what are you doing it's like your entire front
line is dead you're just like what the fuck like what
happened it's like oops tanks dead because you looked away
for one second at chat
that's like another issue I have.
My but Rival is Supports are like, it's just an, I think
it's an easier game.
I know there's a lot of drama though for both.
Um, both games at the moment.
It's crazy.
I think the funny one.
I think the funny one is where like, I think it was an easy
one.
esport team that was uh talking shit about another esport
team and the dev was like take that post down right now i
was like whoa that's wild i was like that's wild holy shit i
was like oh my god esport will always continue to give and
people are gonna be really weird to see me on line i haven't
been playing for a while oh yeah then they disabled in-game
chat and owl yeah i heard that too bro that there's so much
crazy shit in uh overwatch right now too apparently i saw um
what was it oh my i'm trying to remember i mean the funny
the the oh my i'm trying to remember oh yeah people were
calling each other out and shit and being like uh be like
you roster like this roster would have been so good um and
then um and then the guy was like well you like they're like
yeah but you uh you ruined the roster and shit like that i
was just like what the fuck is going on like every esport
like overwatch and rivals are both like having their own
internal esport drama it was insane all right let's see i
don't remember like uh okay wait i don't even remember like
uh but but but but what the sound what my sound settings
were for this so let me figure this out okay let me make
myself a little tiny i think I'm going to be tinier, right?
There you go.
All right.
Immersion.
Locked.
No immersion for you guys.
I won't play paleo for too long because I still have to do
some stuff.
I didn't want to stream for just an hour.
So let me save the sound settings for this was Halo.
So this time I will remember the Halo sound settings.
this time hello oh my god for octom a few days ago oh my god
it's so stupid i had a fire alarm a few days ago i think it
was like and then like um it's so fucking dumb also i
remember at the twitch chat needs to be a little lower so
you guys can see people dying and stuff um see people died
and stuff i almost forgot about that where the fuck is it
give me a sec let me and grab the twitch chat overlay real
quick and it was so dumb because it was like uh because you
know i have like this issue trying to figure out if um the
fire alarm is real or not because like every single fire
alarm has been a false alarm so i'm always stuck in this
hard like you know you know you should always go down if
it's a fire alarm but then there's been like so many false
fire alarms boy who cried wolf you know and you're just like
is this a real fire alarm so i was like debating for a while
and i was like you know what this must be a real fire alarm
you know like i was just like i i was like not i was like i
shouldn't take my chances like should i gamble with my life
today and then so i was about to head like i was about to
like head out and then i was just like do i take the
elevator or take the stairs so I was like you know I'll take
the elevator it's still working because I live very very
high up and it's going to be a while till I head till I get
no you have to guys I cannot tell you guys how many floors I
am it is very very high up because I was like if this is a
false alarm anyway I was about to do it and then the
intercom went off and was like um this is a fault this is
this is not a drill and then the intercom went i was like
this is not a drill and i was like oh fuck and then and then
two seconds you know i was like i'm gonna i'm oh no and then
two seconds later sorry this is a false alarm if you are in
the stairs right now please go back to your apartment this
is a false alarm so you know one thing i was like holy shit
it's a real fight and then later it's like this is a false
alarm i was like oh okay i can go back yay
i was like oh yeah it was a false alarm oh yeah yeah ninja
thank you for the hundred biddies thank you thank you
yeah and i was right so don't so yeah i was just like oh my
god i'm actually being punished right now and then later
they're like this is this was actually a why the fuck would
you start that why would you start like how do you press the
wrong button by the way if it was a false alarm how do you
fucking start off with press the wrong button to be like
This is not a drill.
Like,
the fact that they fucking fucked up and said, this is not a
drill.
Jakarta, thank you for the Twitch Prime.
Thank you.
JK.
It was a drill.
Um, but yeah, that's what happened a couple of days.
ago pretty wild wild dokey day i gotta check my audio okay i
really wanted you know i want to try i'm gonna do a quick
match real quick because i want to i want to try white fox i
only play like white fox like three times but like i don't
think i put my player in ring but she seems fun i just she's
so hard because i'm so bad at melee character so When I
press E, I'm like, what the fuck do I do?
I, like, flip to the enemy side.
She's fun.
She is fun, but it was like...
I was confused when I have to do the combo.
Her combo is hard.
I think it's hard because I just not reflex for me.
Like, I just...
You know, it's because it's, like, new.
She's just new.
always hard.
I hate learning new things.
But the one thing that made me sad about Overwatch was that
I was like, I was like one of the Lucio players back in
early season.
But Lucio has changed so much over so many seasons that I'm
fucking ass at him now.
And it like, it actually tilts me knowing that I'm ass at
Lucio.
Because I used to be like one of the Lucio players.
30 seconds before you attack.
Get ready.
Like, back in the early days of Overwatch.
But, like, the, like, I just don't know how to play Lucio's
new playstyle.
Because, like, he's more Reddit Lucio now.
Back then, it wasn't Reddit Lucio.
Back then, it was more, like, teen player Lucio.
Um, but now, like, he is, like, Reddit Lucio now.
So, like, I'm so ass on him.
And, like, and I get, like, I used to be, like, so good at,
like, staying live.
And now, like, everybody can kill me.
All you need to do is capture the mission area.
Got it?
Oh,
yeah, I hear you can, like, do that, and shit.
I need to remember to use that.
Oh, yeah, like, because they...
Look at that.
Look at that!
Come over here!
Oh, she's faster than me.
She's faster than me.
I forgot that I can, like...
Ricochet your heels too.
Oh my god.
Adam and White Fox.
That does not seem like a good heel combo, but I guess we
are what we are.
What the fuck is she doing there?
That's right!
I don't know what I'm doing!
Yeah!
That's right!
Alright, that's fine.
What the fuck is he doing?
Get out of here.
Who knows?
Let's fucking go.
The thing about quick- Oh yeah, I heard quick play is like
super try hard now, which is crazy to think about.
Because it's fucking quick play, you know?
Nice.
Come on, get over here!
Get over here!
I can't get to you!
I don't know where you are!
Boom!
Okay, something's gonna happen, right?
Like...
Hello, guys.
Hello, what's going on?
Oh, first death.
Okay, maybe I should have left.
Oh, nice!
Four and again aside if I was never gone!
It's like, oh, whoop.
Oh, whoop.
That's five.
Five big booms.
It's like I never left.
Whoa!
I'll get out of here.
Where are you?
What?
Oh, shit.
I fucked up.
There's this quick play.
I don't know what's same honestly say I don't know what's
going on where Fox is just literally press all buttons for
me I'm literally I'm just pressing all buttons and hoping it
works
the great thing about is I don't really actually have to aim
this okay I need to don't worry I got you Oh, fuck.
I never mind.
It landed on the fucking way.
Can I grab the...
I grabbed the fucking thing.
Are you serious?
I didn't realize you can grab the squirrel girl.
What the fuck?
I didn't just take that.
Because I grabbed that shit.
That's so dumb.
I should not be grabbing that.
Okay, I thought I could.
Oh, shit.
Yeah, take the help.
Grab the nuke.
Alright, I gotta actually focus.
Can I, like, actually?
Okay, it's so tiny.
Like, the notification.
Let's go.
Let's fucking go.
That's fucking right.
Big boom!
My turn!
The Dumpo!
The Dumpo Chun-Lu!
Alright, that's your name, right?
All right.
Nobody's dead, Adam.
Nobody's dead.
What the fuck?
Why?
I'm gonna say, nobody's dead.
Who are we?
Who are we doing that to?
Wait, we're double.
There's no way.
We're actually...
Wait a minute.
We're running triple.
There's no way.
We're actually running triple.
What are we?
I'm in quick play.
What the fuck is going on?
There is no way we're running triple and quickslay.
That's crazy.
That's actually crazy.
That's insane.
Me dying just makes this game more fair.
I had to die for this game to be more fair.
This is also why I sort of stopped playing Rivals I was just
really tired of I was really tired of triple support MVP
let's go why is this so that's what I'm saying GG no heals I
don't even know what the fuck i was doing apparently i
healed them let's go most healing don't know how nothing
ever changed and there's also why i was just like i wasn't
just i just wasn't a fan of of triple support being like
just so prominent in rivalries that i just just haven't
played as much i was just so tired of triple support the
goat's drum oh yeah they have what's his they have made was
it made cafe where is it is it out yet or is it it wasn't
leaked
what life oh it's not out yet oh it's in two days okay just
showed it all right i don't i i okay i'll say it i'm not a
huge fan of the professor professor skin because like like
i'm like you know i'm like damn yeah let's go like i know
what like we are we know what sorry but i was just like
where are you looking at i'm just thinking like
you're me like she's a professor you know so i'm like
thinking if i'm in class i'll be like where can i attend
thinking what perfect you're right all right perfect
attendance i'm thinking perfect attendance right there uh
next to you thinking with the hundred bitties thank you
thank you I like how this was like The Phoenix Ray Pose.
Objection!
Well, I'm gonna get yelled at.
Oh, I forgot.
Are there drops?
Do I need to put drops down?
That was the one thing I was trying to figure out.
Guys, are there drops?
Yes, there are.
Alright, let me put the drops.
Let me put that on the title drops yeah what even is meta
fuck man I'm worried about playing invisible woman because
everyone like everyone talks shit about oh wait cloak and
dagger I heard cloak and dagger is super strong so
all right spotty last okay never mind there we go man deep
and rogue he isn't how did oh my god these people been
playing oh yeah tank pool is really hard meta right now oh
as long well we'll see if hook and dagger gets bad all right
let's see what's gonna happen oh we have a e-couple
let's go we have a e-couple that's third wheel all right
also Elsa yeah I heard Elsa's really good hey no support
bands okay never mind never mind um what we're going gambit
oh wait I have to go no what okay this is bad now we have
too many support players how are you how are you doing
together you're both support players that's like the worst
part that's real love you're an e-couple and you're both
play support you you're both there's no top in this
relationship they're both and they're both they're both i
don't play solo sorry i'll play solo then i'm getting off
misses oh my god i almost forgot word the card one they're
both bottoms i just i'm not that good you're a top 500
support go play dps what the is going on but
it's been so long i'm gonna get yelled at guys we have four
support players i will get yelled at by one of the
supporters being mad at me i i will get yelled at because
they're like you're so bad on and then i have to play gambit
loki too That's the worst.
That's the fucking worst.
Oh my god, I haven't played in so long, actually.
I forgot I had the low keys before I came to heal me.
Oh no.
I'm gonna get yelled at, guys.
Oh my god.
This is not good for me.
This is not good.
Oh my, this should not be my first game.
This should not be my first game.
Holy fuck.
The fact that I have this as my first game back.
Holy shit.
this I did not expect myself to play Loki gambit as my first
oh my god oh my Guys, you have to, I have.
It's been a while, guys.
I'm just like, I'm copying 20 different players.
I can't believe this is my first game.
This is my first game back today.
I copied.
like three different people.
I was like, I swear Gavin is in front of me.
How the fuck am I?
How the fuck am I not popping him?
Alright, guys.
I don't feel comfortable.
I'm fucking swap.
Oh, guess not.
I want to swap off, guys.
I need to play Luna.
I'm too tired right now to play I'm like low-key All right
guys, I have yet to get yelled at that is good that is not
getting yelled at right now that is good
Okay, not getting yelled at so far
All right, there you go
fuck i'm so not used to aiming with low-key right now i've
been playing like
all right
oh there you go
oh this is where i died this is where i died yeah thank you
for the rate thank you thank you i'm in l right now i did
not want this to be my first game back and I've been actual
hell why do we not ban gambit I thought that was like the
one thing we all know to ban like I thought that was the one
thing we we all agreed on no matter what doesn't matter what
meta we had we had a ban gambit please it's it's my first
game back please there we go Here we go, first copy!
Alright.
Yep.
There we go.
Who are we?
We're dead.
Oh, we're so dead.
Unfortunately, I queued...
My team has four support players.
It's just... It is just very unfortunate.
We actually have four support players, so like, honestly,
I'm surprised we made it this far.
Oh my god.
Save him.
Save this man.
He's a professor.
He's a doctor.
Save the doctor!
I live
for as long as I thought I was gonna live I oh my god I'm
surprised I lived there as long as I could well it's like
it's like unfortunate circumstances circumstances where um
we have four support players no dps players um and then i
have to play gambit loki as my first game back after having
not touched rivals and so i'm not playing loki i can't i'm
not strong enough i'm tired it's like and the fact that to
play loki gambit at three in the morning like 2 30 in the
morning bro like
Like, I'm thinking I'm not here for that.
Like, 2.30 in the morning for Loki Gambit.
I thought, like, I thought, I thought it was over.
Like, I'm so rusty.
I'm so fucking...
I have not played...
I've not played a healing character like Loki in so long.
It's like a side, like the fact that it was my first game
too, it was, if it was like a third or fourth game, I'd be
maybe a bit more warmed up, but this being my first game is
like, it's not the greatest.
It is absolutely not the greatest.
I might have to avoid the the e-couple because like why
would you ever e-couple as a supply as two supports like
like that's hell
that's actually like hell I don't know why you would ever do
that to yourself like how is that that's such a gamble I
can't see us be like we don't know if Like maybe we just
don't have enough support players, but I feel like you would
always have enough support players With triple support being
meta Like they're in fact we have an abundance of support
players at this point Like Like We might have too many
support players We're not killing anything We have no DPS
players We're not killing anything We're not killing
anything
We have so many Oh
What Give me the voice.
Oh, I'm on East Coast.
I'm on East Coast.
Oh, okay.
I'm I'm on East Coast I didn't lose my ult though.
My ult is still there.
I was just on East Coast I was just like what do you mean I
die Oh, I have my ult for next fight, I guess.
For rivals too.
I almost said Overwatch too.
It's fine.
I'll be free from this hellhole soon.
I'm just sending it out into the fucking abyss.
Can we live?
Like, can we even live here?
Holy shit.
Oh my god, please.
Please have mercy.
Please.
Hey, I live.
All right, I need it, though.
It's okay.
It's almost over.
It's almost over, guys.
We're almost free.
One more...
This has been the longest four-minute fight of my life.
This truly has been...
I hope everyone has a word each other so no this team will
never come together ever again This team so this team will
never Will never meet up ever again in life like I hope I
hope we all avoid each other no this team will never come
together Oh, I don't need it.
It's bad.
I'm just a simple Oh
Can we, like, kill him?
Like, how is he still there?
Like, how is he?
Oh, hey, guys.
Okay, I was gonna say, oh, no, guys.
Why would you ever even...
Why would you ever cap?
Why would you not free me from this existence?
Why would you cap?
I don't understand.
Do you not want to leave?
Like...
why would you ever want to keep going I would just I would
just like leave the car you know
oh my god they like actually
alright they're gonna have Groot all hey but we all live
though What they would actually have
Where did he go?
Holy shit, he's so fast What the fuck?
Surely you all do That's funny, that's funny
That's Surely Oh my god.
Hey, at least I'm practicing for next week, guys.
At least I'm practicing for next week.
I needed to learn Rivals again anyway.
I forgot how, like, fast, too.
I swear, Overwatch is so slow compared to...
I think Overwatch is a lot slower.
The fights feel a lot slower.
slower but like in rivals it's i there's so many things
going on my screen it's just like a lot of stuff graphics in
my in my in my eye are you a streamer i don't know if i am
the problem but
I just hope that Hey, I froze her I froze her, why is she
still here?
Why is she still here?
Oh my god Why is she moving?
I thought she was frozen?
Please Oh, thank god we all left Final score One, two,
three.
Very tight.
You know what?
I'm just happy.
Like, I'm freed.
I could have been freed four minutes ago.
I don't know how.
I was still stuck in this eternal hell.
How did I get more damage than our gambit?
I didn't even know what the fuck was going on.
half the time.
I didn't even know.
Oh my God.
I should not have more damage than Gavin.
That's one thing I remember.
I'm just surprised I got more damage.
I...
Alright.
Okay.
How do I avoid people again?
How do I... How do I avoid people?
all right um i have to avoid one of these guys they're
they're obviously grouped up together so at least like
that's two support players i don't have to fight with um
then gamma get a damage nerf yeah but he's like a kiriko
isn't he where you like he's all about damage versus like
heals like it's all about taking off angles and stuff i
thought i mean unless they change how have to play gambit we
weren't running triple support yet somehow oh yeah that's
crazy we like we were fucking getting we were getting farmed
so hard oh they swapped altrons the altrons swapped so you
can tell here um man that's a man
Ah!
It was a nice yellow break road.
You didn't see here.
Everyone was a support player.
Okay, it was...
We have four support players.
Yeah, we have four support players.
It's just that.
We literally had four support players.
I'm avoiding the duo support players.
Just because, like, you know, that's one less support to
player to worry about and then I'm hoping that everybody in
that team avoided someone so like there will never be this
combination this team will never be together ever again I
think that's like number one thing you never play with
someone in the same role unless you're DPS is that a DPS the
only time you can double roll queue is DPS, because the DPS
can flex to support a tank more easily than a supporter tank
player.
But to support duo is just so risky.
It's way too risky.
Don't worry.
Oh my god, I'm actually so tired.
What were the new things they added?
They added anything new to the time.
Oh wait, that's new.
Wait.
What's the statue?
Oh, Holy shit.
Wait, she has a bird now?
I want to be in the pool.
I want to dance in the pool.
Hey guys, the pool is open.
You guys want to join in on the hot tub action?
Oh yeah, you can ride the Jeff now.
I forgot about that.
Jeff doing.
Alright, there's so many new things.
Alright, someone changed my... I gotta change my category to
Hot Toastreamer.
He's getting hot in here.
Wow.
Alright.
Okay, that's good.
Everyone's different.
God, that pool is not cooling that Venom down.
Guys, if we lose this game, say i'm just gonna call it ggs i
don't think i'm strong enough right now if i if i have to
play gambit lurky again i i'm i don't know guys i don't know
if i'm strong enough the fact that it was literally my first
game back too it's been like 20 years it's been 20 years and
they have had to chuck me in with gambit i'm banning gambit
I don't care.
Oh, thank God.
All right, there we go.
There we go.
I was just like, I can't.
I just can't do this again.
I can't.
Fuck.
I'm not strong enough.
Well, you ban a tank pool.
I'm pretty sure.
I'm a banning tank pool just in case.
just in case because we don't have a tank pool player I know
tank pool is strong because of I watched a bit of MRI last
week was this last week yeah and I just saw everybody
playing tank pool see nobody is against my band so I was
right alright where do I go triple let's go triple support
Someone tried to lie to me and being like, triple support is
not that popular in rank anymore.
And I was like, oh, yeah, sure.
I was just like, sure, it's not.
And I pulled up the one, and I pulled up the first stream.
I was like, no, you're just ready.
I pulled up the first stream, and it was literally triple
support versus triple support.
Okay.
It's like, literally.
I was like, what the fuck were you talking about?
I literally saw triple support in quick play.
My very first game I queued.
And then my very first ranked triple support.
And then at least this is not triple support.
But the enemy team goes triple support.
I swear to God.
Triple support is like a crutch comp.
I think.
It's like if nothing works, you go triple support.
higher chance of because even if 222 is not working then
triple support is like you're like hell merry you know what
i mean it's like it's my last attempt on trying to make it
work
why are you jumping bet
hello hey that nice i'll go
Whoa, I need to reload, so I hope the white fox can heal
him.
I'm just gonna push cart.
I'm gonna be a little cart baby.
I don't people just read Moon Knight?
Because Moon Knight fucking sucks.
It's ass.
Also, that Starloid?
I was surprised he didn't fucking kill me.
Had it all this time, you know?
Where the fuck was that?
I don't even know where I was shooting that I will be honest
my eyes are blurring together right now which is not great
it's not great I'm just not used to how fast everything is
since I've been playing Overwatch for so long
every like I think it also doesn't help that I am tired.
My eyes are tired right now.
Your muscle memory.
Yeah, I'm not used to it.
I'm trying to get used to it again.
Alright.
Why are you...
Okay, I was gonna...
I was gonna say, why are you even trying to challenge that
magic?
You're not invincible.
I mean, good effort I guess that well why there you go Fox
time let's go okay I can still that's good to know I can
still do that I can still freeze that's good to know yeah I
still got it guys I still got it I still got it oh shit I
have another one and forgot my i forgot my other bro okay
the fact i did all that without knowing my other ability
i'm still at it
where the fuck is my magic okay i was gonna say magic you're
supposed to be going in soon
there's no saving me there i don't know guys if i own i
would have been dead I knew I knew it was obi I knew it was
so obi Okay, I wasn't gonna help that I didn't want to waste
my own I should have put that on the on the Angela At least
I have my own now I know who I
Boom Alright, I'm gonna save my ult.
Don't worry.
We can wait a little bit.
Never mind.
There's no reason to force an ult here.
Alright.
There you go.
Oh, shit.
Okay, I didn't know.
Okay, we're committing?
Alright, we're committing.
We're committing.
Alright.
There you go.
Oh!
Okay, that was an explosion.
Okay, we are a little staggered, I will say.
I will say this is a little bit of a staggered right now.
I need you guys to regroup one by one.
Just into this pit of people.
They're not mangled soon, too, so I don't know about that.
Oh, can't have Magot if he's dead.
Alright.
Oh.
Maybe?
Okay.
I'm gonna be like, it'll be fine, right?
Guys, it was not fine.
I'm tempted to pull out the rocket.
I'm certain.
tempted i wanted to play luna just speak to practice aiming
again because it's been so long but at this point i might
actually just go i might just go rocket just to like get
back into the groove of things you know i'll just give this
to him so i don't have to worry about
oh he definitely has up he's looking for it
the miss he was just such a skinny boy hey cat oh he's still
looking for it
holy he got deleted that's crazy okay i actually need to get
the up though
oh my gosh i can do it
oh my god please i'm so tired my eyes are so tired please
have mercy on me please My eyes are so tired right now.
I'm...
You know how, like, when you feel the eyes straining, like,
that's me right now.
I feel the strain.
Please tell me we fucking try and destroy it.
We don't.
Oh, no.
Oh, my God.
My eyes actually was like, I'm so tired.
The current score is one, two, zero.
All right.
It's time.
I think I'm tired of aiming.
I'm wondering that.
I don't think like, it was good in the first half.
The second half got a little bad.
You know where your eyes feel strained because you're just
like, please stop moving.
moving.
I was just like, please stop.
I was like, I've been playing an FPS game in like a week.
I've been work, work, week, week.
I'm just trying to remember.
My freezes were nutty though.
All right, guys, at least we can all agree.
Am I freezes?
My freezes though?
At least that was on point.
I'll take those.
At least now I can stop aiming.
Meow.
The battle starts in five, four, three, two one why i'm
sorry don't watch back the stream
that's all i ask is all i don't watch it back i may or may
not have not been aiming there's a reason why i went to
rocket all right here we go oh i forgot he was he's on
phoenix why the fuck am i on rocket wait a minute wait a
wait a minute whoops my pure gallantry what the do i play
then
Oh, that's nothing.
Dude, that's the worst part.
There's nothing to do with my up.
Like, I literally can't do anything.
Yeah.
Hey, just live.
Just live.
Just live, everyone.
Yay!
I'm doing stuff.
This isn't Zaya.
I can just...
I'm not building charge.
I can actually shoot the bubble.
That's good.
I can actually shoot the shields.
Alright, guys, ready to see a Phoenix Alt, guys?
Yes.
You guys ready?
It's gonna be a sick-ass Phoenix Alt.
Pretty enemy team.
Okay, look, I did.
I try.
I try to give it up.
I didn't realize he would fucking swerve it into the tunnel.
That's crazy.
He actually swerved it into the tunnel.
Oh.
That was...
I'm surprised, honestly.
You know, good for us.
Okay, not for him, though.
Good for it.
Little, little ring.
Little ring of heals.
Oh, yo.
That's strange is not a strange player.
You can tell.
You can tell that strange is not really strange.
That is crazy how we survive that long.
Good for us.
What?
Hey.
Hey, hey guys.
Hey guys.
You're still here, guys.
Oh, I thought we were... You know what?
We still...
Oh, we should have used.
Oh, wait.
Unless someone's gonna...
Oh wait Okay, I do have an armor pack if he dies
There we go, can we touch?
Can we touch?
I'm on here, touch!
Get here!
Whoa, okay, maybe no longer
I'm just chilling
That's right.
Get him.
Oh, fuck.
I'm sorry.
Yippee.
Oh, no.
They have a strange portal, though.
Right here.
Okay, we gotta kill this guy.
All right.
Yay.
They did it.
I don't have to aim.
Yeah.
I was just a little I was just a little little pesky little
raccoon I can't believe you killed that I can't believe
nobody shot me I got a little too cocky though I was just
like you know I'm gonna shoot back that was a mistake I
thought I was stronger I really did I thought I was I was
like I have a machine gun what could go wrong
Yay!
Whoops, I forgot to queue.
I was surprised we held that.
Good for us.
I didn't need to prove anything.
I went to Rocket.
I didn't...
Yay!
I didn't have to...
Network fluctuation!
What happened?
What happened here?
Holy shit!
What the fuck happened here?
Did I, like, move to, like...
Like, it's Apollo?
Oh my god.
Stokey lags, which...
That's why they couldn't get me.
That's my secret.
I lagged switch when they try to get me there.
Pat in there.
Oh, I finally got the fast-ass mouse.
The X2 Super Strike.
I don't have... I'm not using it now.
Because, like, I'm too lazy, so it's still, like, in the box
right now.
Alright.
Oh, my God.
Big pool party.
You can't even see me twerk.
I'm just gonna swim.
Hang out with my buddies.
Hey.
It's a little pool party.
Can't even see me.
Whoa.
whoa I'm so tired okay last this might be my LG depending on
how I feel this could be my LG my eyes are watering I didn't
realize how much faster the game was after spending so much
time on Overwatch I'm not like tired tired though like I'm
not, like, sleepy-tired.
It's just, like, I'm overstimulated, you know?
That's how I feel right now.
I'm just overstimulated.
I'm not, like, sleepy-tired.
This is, like, a lot on my screen.
Overwatch Refugee.
Bro, just hella Differ, bro.
You got that.
It's just that easy.
Just Differ, bro.
What are you, a fucking pussy?
Just fucking differ.
What in the Xbox mic?
Alright, we wait.
Alright, I'm ready.
I'm so ready.
Okay, that's good.
No Gambit.
That's good.
Bro,
everyone knows everybody.
I fucking lost track of who's who.
um all right let's go no aim
yeah i'm here to prove the cloak and dagger stereotype let's
go one support let's go
it's okay guys it's king of the hill it'll end faster
I'm here to reinforce the stereotype.
Let's go.
This suffering will be quick.
Unless someone asks for duo, this could be LG.
I need someone to bring down with me.
I need someone I know to bring down their Elo.
It's not the same when I'm bringing down random people Elo.
You know?
You know what I mean?
But Shepo is never touching Rivalence again.
Alright.
Watch this.
I'm going to get...
I'm going to get clipped.
And then they'll be like...
I swear to God.
These cloak and dagger players.
They're a different breed.
And I'm like, that's me.
He clipped.
Oh my God.
They're talking about me.
Oh,
there you go.
All right, I might have...
Oh, there.
Nice.
It's hard.
Not all cloaking daggers, but always a cloaking dagger.
Oh, my God.
I can't wait.
Find me on Twitter.
Why is someone mad at cloaking daggers?
Oh, man.
Oh, my God.
I forgot I can't crouch in this game.
I've been crouch spamming a lot.
I forgot crouch because there's no crouch in this game
crouch is my I need healing Because I would crouch when
there's a sniper so I'm not used to like not actually
crouching
Body block from me punish it
All right There we go.
Wow, you got a lot easier when All right, fuck it That's
right!
Not all cloaking dagger players, but all cloaking dagger
players.
We didn't need to ult that.
There you go.
I mean, we got point at least.
I was like, oh man, if I ult this, I'm pretty sure people
would...
Solo tankful.
I mean, it's stupid.
It's doable.
We have, we do not have, we do not have Luna.
We do not have Luna.
Maybe.
All right.
I mean, that's fine.
I mean, I got myself, like, I saved myself.
All right, here we go.
My time to shine.
I legitimately thought, to be fair.
I thought we had Luna on it.
But unfortunately, what the fuck?
Alright, guys.
Guys, stay in the orb.
Why do I make an orb if nobody stays on it?
Like, nobody.
Luna, Luna, why would you go out?
Okay.
Alright.
There we go.
I'm very confused with my team, but that's fine.
Do we not have a Luna?
I don't think we do.
I think maybe?
Not all Luna players, but Luna players, maybe?
Wait, how?
There's a...
Okay, that's fine.
anything this is master this is grant master or a dagger I
think he only went to his portal I'm pretty sure we still
have Luno though guys we still have Luno though we still
have Luno though okay oh
There is still that guy over here.
I have not held I've just been left-clicking.
I don't know any other buttons in this game I feel like I
Don't know any other button.
I
Just okay.
I just all right now I can left-click I'm sorry if you die
to that I mean, like...
Oh, that's bad for me.
That's bad.
That's very bad for me.
Hello, Luna.
I hope you're okay.
Nope.
I saved myself at least.
Yeah, I was like, I'm alive.
At least...
At least I'm alive.
It just sucks because we don't have a...
ult to counter...
to match it.
to match 20 other ults.
You know what?
It's not my fault.
I might be on cloak and dagger, but it's not my fault.
I certainly think I felt like I just pressed left click the
entire it was like no everyone just kept being low I'm
hunting criminals Wade not throwing a birthday party for a
six-year-old I'm a streamer streamers don't make mistakes
guys I'm keeping this in oh I'll cut them off.
I want TP's done.
I'll cut them in half.
All right.
I don't think Magic understood the plan.
Goodbye, Magic.
Wait, maybe because...
Oh, no, he just doesn't care.
Oh my god, what the...
I mean...
How did he get?
What did he even get?
Oh my god!
Okay.
Wait, where's the point?
There's the point.
What?
Okay, my ult was literally right there.
I don't know how.
How?
I don't...
I don't know how everyone stood away from my ult.
Um...
It was...
I will say my ult was right there.
Okay.
I might have, could have alted forward, but I was literally
like confused where the point was.
That was my bad.
That was just me not remembering where we were.
That was me forgetting what direction I'm in.
Okay.
Can you really blame me?
That's bad for him.
Hello Rocket.
You'll be fine.
There we go.
So yeah, see everything?
Not always cloak and dagger.
But usually cloak and dagger.
I would take the blame that I didn't ult straight to the
point.
But also, they could have stood on my own.
It was over there.
It was not in a weird-ass place.
I feel.
Oh, what the fuck?
That's crazy.
Okay, I do think we should have...
Wait, we have Rocket up.
Why did we not Rocket up?
Okay.
The renex upped it, and he kept it.
up what the fuck i was throwing that down the moment i was
like okay rocket hold any moment any second now any any
second and any second it's gonna be here i literally waited
for the rocket
any second now guys all right there is a chance that i will
die
Unless...
Never mind.
Moving on.
Unless...
Oh shit, give me a sec.
Hey guys, there is a...
Our rocket is fighting Phoenix right now.
Oh yeah, in the fucking...
Alright.
Alright, it's five.
it's okay we got all charged i got half of 50 from that i'll
take that a rocket it's not good it's not good that i'm mvp
it's not good at all it's not good i'm a i'm on cloak and
dagger it is not good
it's absolutely not good i am not comfortable with that All
right, get ready for another cloak and dagger roll.
All right, this is where he uses it.
This is where he uses it.
This is...
All right, not here, but all right.
Not in here.
But okay.
Oh.
I don't know why he put it He put it in the corner I was so
confused Why this was in I was so confused This is bad I
didn't have to At least I'm not MVP That makes me Put it,
like, out in there where we were all fighting.
I was just like, guys, the rocket made some very
questionable plays.
Is that just someone pretending it to be me?
Guys, I would never admit it was me if someone asked me.
That's your first clue.
It's not because they're diamond or anything.
If anyone asked me, is that jokie red?
I'd be like, no.
I'll never admit it.
Wait.
Are you ready for your Disney Plus ads?
Let's go.
What's playing right now on Disney Plus?
Oh my, I thought that was Apex at first.
I was like, damn, is that an Apex ad in my Marvel Rivals?
Oh, hey, pizza.
in so long.
What the fuck is this?
What show is this?
Pizza, do you have an account?
That's GM.
Come to rank with me.
We'll see.
You have an account and GM.
Come to rank right now.
Run, pizza.
Run.
y'all i am missing every shot i'm taking right now i you
don't have a gm account worthless i'm worthless i'm
worthless i'm in this piss though i'm the worthless one
oh they're gonna add so many characters before doomsday or
whatever i don't know if i want to solo queue another one
these games have been pretty rough.
These games have been pretty questionable.
Alright.
Well, Pizza doesn't have an account.
And I just went through.
I just went through some.
Some very questionable games.
It's surprising.
Like, I didn't do that badly.
After I swapped off, like, in characters.
Actually, no.
No, no.
it started off okay it started off alright I was hit I was
actually hitting shots and it's just started getting worse
over time over time I was just too overstimulated because I
wasn't used to all these but all these fancy VFX on my
screen I was like oh yeah they added more visual effects I
forgot about that and I was like i'm tired now i feel like i
my eyes my eyes aged like 80 years in that one game that i
had to play as luna but anyway guys i'm gonna call it here
i'm gonna call it here i didn't want to solo another one and
i'll uh i'll rest my eyes now but i hope you guys had a fun
time watching um it was it was an adventure playing the uh
playing a couple of games and rivals again i have i had to
warm i had to like remember how i played this game but uh if
you're new here please check me out on youtube um this was
like a real stream today on twitch because i wanted to
stream today to relax for them all the work that i've been
doing behind the scenes it's been very stressful behind the
scenes and honestly i'm just i'm talking to you guys makes
me feel a lot better that makes me feel less stressed out um
so it was nice to just hang out with you guys uh uh relaxer
rivals is less stressful than what i have to do behind the
scenes at the moment i'll just say that everything will
reveal itself soon it'll all reveal itself soon um but it
was it's definitely less stressful right now um anyway guys
please check me out on youtube that's usually where i stream
my on my main channel um please check me on twitter you want
to know one of our stream on twitch uh and if you want to
support me via other means i have merch right now so there's
all the merch websites dokey merch senpai squad and yeah
that should be everything as always everybody say hi i'm
ready to pause check get a move around to get that blood
flowing can you stay up for me head to bed because you
deserve it i'll see you guys next time everybody bye guys
bye